Speaker 1: take a very quick break.
Don't hang up because we're going right back
to the phones in a moment.
Let's hear from a few more people, folks who
are waiting to chat.
You can use our discord.
David Pacman dot com slash discord.
Why don't we go next to Seth from Nebraska?
Seth from Nebraska.
Welcome to the David Pakman show.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hi, David.
First time caller, if you can hear me.
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Awesome.
So I had a question.
My wife and I were having a discussion, actually,
last night.
She is fearful of the future when it comes
to, you know, like Republicans and these policies
that they're passing, as you know, they're
just not popular, but they keep getting through.
And I'm a little bit more optimistic, like
boomers are essentially dying off and worse
animals.
And I think millennials and Gen Z are like
the largest voting bloc now.
Yeah, I just wanted to know kind of your opinion
on if I don't see that this is sustainable
for the Republicans to just, you know, push
through all these unpopular ideas.
But, you know, like I said, my wife is fearful
that it's just going to keep happening and,
you know, our rights are going to get diminished
and democracy is failing and all that.
I just kind of wanted to know your thoughts.
Speaker 1: Well, so here's the thing.
Let's deal with the the fear part first.
Okay.
One of the.
One of the realities is that in the United
States, if you live in Massachusetts, Connecticut,
Minnesota, New Hampshire, New Jersey, Colorado,
the standard of living as measured by the
HDI Human Development Index is very similar
to being in Switzerland, Norway, Iceland,
Hong Kong, you know, the places with the highest
overall standards of living.
With that metric human development index in
those states, regardless of what Republicans
do in Louisiana and regardless of what a president
does to some degree, right at the federal
level, you can start to impact states.
Life on average is going to remain very good
in the blue states with very high standard
of living and again, in order by HDI.
It's Massachusetts, Connecticut, Minnesota,
New Hampshire, Jersey, Colorado.
Washington, D.C..
Hawaii.
Okay.
In other states, it's not going to be so good.
So I see that you're calling, for example,
from Nebraska, Nebraska, in terms of HDI,
I think is kind of like right in the middle.
I'm looking at it right now.
It's like it's not terrible.
It's not actually Nebraska's.
Okay, Nebraska's 13th in the country.
So unfortunately, what happens is when you
have Democratic presidents and Democratic
houses and Senates, things get a little bit
better for everyone.
And then when you have Republican presidents
and Republican governors, etc., things get
a little worse for everyone, but they get
particularly worse for a lot of these red
states that don't have their own protections
already built in.
And so, sadly, listen, things can get bad
everywhere.
There's no question about it.
But sadly, the first people to be damaged
by Republicans succeeding, as you point out,
are going to disproportionately be Republican
voters.
Now, what we do with this information, what
you and your wife personally do, I don't really
know.
Speaker 3: Yeah, we just recently had I forget
what the bill was, is the abortion ban at
12 weeks, which lumped into there was transgender
affirming care for anyone under I think 19.
But then they also voted on the same day for
permit lists concealed carry.
Right.
And none of those were popular bills at all.
We were protesting inside the Capitol so loudly
that they had to stop the debating inside
the chambers, but they still passed it.
And that was, you know, I have a few friends
that have trans kids.
And, you know, it's kind of heavy right now
in Nebraska.
So everybody's just a little bit worried.
Thank you for your thoughts, though.
I appreciate that.
All right.
September 1st.
Speaker 1: Basically have.
Speaker 3: To do better.
Speaker 1: Appreciate the call.
Thank you so much.
Speaker 3: Sara.
Speaker 1: All right.
There he goes.
Why don't we go next to how about Tristan
from Los Angeles?
Tristan, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Oh, hello.
Hello.
I have a pretty open ended question for you.
I just finished watching Secession, and I
was wondering if you had any takeaways from
it, if you've watched it at all?
Speaker 1: No, I don't even think I have.
What is that, like a Showtime show or HBO?
Speaker 3: Yes, And HBO, it's sort of similar
to, I guess, like a murdoch sort of reign.
And the patriarch is ending and then handing
his crown and sort of the machinations of
a large media conglomerate.
Speaker 1: But again, I don't I don't have
HBO, and I haven't seen a single episode.
I my my TV show consumption is really low
these days just because I'm so, so busy.
But a lot of people have said that it is a
great program, but unfortunately, I've not
seen it.
Speaker 3: Next to you with all baby and everything.
Speaker 1: Exactly.
Now, where are you from?
Australia.
Speaker 3: Yep.
Speaker 1: Okay.
And you live in the US?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: What's that like?
What's the what's the biggest cultural difference
you find in the U.S. from Australia?
Speaker 3: Positive or negative either.
I don't know.
I think.
Speaker 1: Well, how about positive first?
Speaker 3: If there is.
There's less of a tall poppy syndrome here.
But to me in Australia, sometimes it can feel
like, okay, if you try to do something different,
people will try and bring you back into the
fold.
Keep, keep that field of poppies the same
height.
But I think it's guns.
It's just it's so normalized here.
And I could be talking with very liberal people
and next thing you know, like, oh yeah, we're
going to go shoot shotguns, which is not negative
or positive.
It's just incredibly different.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: And in Australia is that extremely,
extremely rare since the laws have been changed
around owning weapons.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah, Yeah.
It.
I knew a kid who grew up on a farm who shot
guns, but that's like literally the only person
I knew.
You knew one.
Speaker 1: Person with guns?
Yeah.
No, that's definitely very different.
That that is definitely different.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
I'll have to think about it.
If I called back.
I'll maybe have a more rounded answer for
you.
Speaker 1: All right.
Tristan from Los Angeles, I appreciate the
call.
Speaker 3: Yeah, thanks for having me.
Speaker 1: All right.
There he goes.
Very powerful stuff.
Let's go to Kenny from Long Island.
Kenny, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
What can I do for you?
Kenny from Long Island.
Don't be the first to drop.
You've got to accept my invitation, sir.
Speaker 3: Oh, boy.
All right, Well.
Speaker 1: That's too bad.
Kenny from Long Island.
We are not going to hear from today.
Let's go to Gerald from Miami.
Now.
Is that Miami, Florida or Miami, Ohio?
Gerald, please unmute so you can answer my
trivia questions.
Oh, boy.
Gerald, you're muting yourself.
You've got to unmute yourself to be able to
talk to me.
Speaker 3: Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, now I can.
Speaker 3: Oh, hi.
Yeah, it's Gerald from Miami, Florida.
Great.
What's on your mind?
Oh, yeah.
I was just curious about, you know, there's
been a lot of talk recently about upcoming,
like, Republican candidates, you know, that
are all jumping into the race for 2024.
And I know Biden has announced that he would
be running.
But I was curious if you had thought about
any other potential like Democratic nominees
that, you know, would have a shot if they
were to jump in the race?
Speaker 1: I don't think any would have a
shot.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean, listen, if this were an open primary,
here's the thing people need to understand.
I, I support people challenging Joe Biden.
I would like there to be debates on the Democratic
side.
If people credibly challenge Joe Biden and
are polling at least, you know, some number
8% or something, which right now I think means
at minimum you would have debates between
biden and bobby kennedy jr.
I don't know where Marianne Williamson is
polling, but I'm I'm in favor of debates.
I'm in favor of a contested primary.
I want people to run.
But if you're asking me, given what is going
on and the fact that the DNC is not incentivized
to have someone challenge the incumbent president
and that there's not going to be a real primary,
I don't think there's anyone who would have
a shot.
I mean, if we if we pick someone with with
mass public appeal, like I don't know if Dwayne
the Rock Johnson announced, would he be able
to generate enough interest because he's charismatic
and whatever, that maybe he could actually
defeat Biden somehow?
I mean, I just think that when you have an
incumbent president, the the odds that have
to be overcome, because when you're an incumbent,
the DNC is going to grease the wheels for
you to remain the nominee.
I don't know that anybody could defeat Joe
Biden given the way that this primary is going
to happen.
Speaker 3: I see.
Yeah.
Yeah, It's just, you know, I've just been
thinking.
I just.
I just feel like, you know, with Joe Biden's
approval or just kind of thinking, I just
didn't know if you would.
Obviously, I didn't really think he could
actually win again.
To be honest with you.
Well, this is just Biden's approval.
Speaker 1: It's not really sinking.
Biden's approval has been steady since August
of last year.
Okay.
So that now is nine months where it's just
been in the low forties.
When you and I look at that, we say, oh, that's
pretty low.
That means like high fifties disapproves of
the job Biden is doing.
Yeah, that's the way it is with presidents
in the United States right now.
The reality is that you can absolutely get
yourself reelected with a 43% approval rating.
We saw George W Bush do it.
You know, it's not Biden's approval is not
the sign to me that he's in trouble.
Speaker 3: Okay.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: All right.
Gerald from Miami.
Great, Great question.
Good to hear from you